come on all that stuff's a joke the
Avengers is the biggest franchise of all
time at this point even beating the
unstoppable juggernaut that was Star
Wars and out grossing blue monkey
ponytail sex at the box office you'd be
hard-pressed to find any person who
hasn't heard of one of these characters
and even more so to find someone who
doesn't love at least one of them it's
difficult to imagine a time before when
these characters were all obscure
nobodies except like Captain America and
maybe Iron Man I mean before the movies
took off before comics and geek culture
became mainstream before slavish
devotion to standing Robert Downey jr.
and Tom Holland on your Twitter account
like it was the new religion was
socially acceptable behavior that didn't
make people assume you look like comic
book guy from The Simpsons back in the
dark times when people looked at you
funny and said you were told to have a
spider-man lunchbox when you were 10 the
first cartoon based on the Avengers
premiered in October 1999 in a world
that didn't have any hype or
expectations of what the Avengers ought
to be like you'd think that would make
this show really refreshing and unique
but boy is it rough around the smoothly
shaded edge over this review topic was
picked for the $100 tier on my patreon
by Mitchell Paul Martinez if you have
something you desperately want to hear
me mispronounce the title of and then
complain about for 10 to 20 minutes you
can go give suggestions through there or
just simply support the channel because
old boy things are getting dicey out
here
stop right there bacteria the Fortuner
career paths aside Avengers United they
stand is a strange little anomaly in the
lineage of beloved superhero cartoons
from the 90s it seems like Marvel and
Fox kids could do no wrong with every
animated series up to this point being a
hit or at least successful enough for a
second season but here we have this show
that I can only assume had a decently
large budget to animate such complex
character designs was based on a brand
that would go on to be the biggest in
human history with starring characters
with enough shared backstory and source
material that they could make like 20
seasons aired on a network where Marvel
cartoons were celebrated and successful
and yet it still failed the low ratings
and poor reception caused the network to
decide not to order a second season the
show had so much going for it but there
were setbacks too it was plagued by
unfortunate behind-the-scenes tomfoolery
that deeply affected the final product
even for everything that could have made
this show work troubles and changing
winds from the real world wouldn't let
it reach its full potential and it only
lasted a very commercialized and
visually loud 13 episodes with a series
identity crisis let's figure out why
Avengers United they stand divided and
fell I'm really proud of that line don't
don't you roll your eyes at me [ __ ]
fine make your own video if you're such
an expert at witty writing Avengers
perhaps some backstory on the production
of the show could shed some light on why
it ultimately turned into a charitably
underwhelming series in the late 90s two
of the x-men no no no no no no no
writers were contacted by Fox executives
to make an Avenger show they typed up a
13-episode outline and they were going
to do a Captain America series alongside
it everything seemed to be going
smoothly then Marvel went bankrupt in
1997 in the avengers project was put on
hold indefinitely while Captain America
show was canceled entirely No I have a
theory that his episode in this show was
a failed backdoor pilot that they forgot
to take out being the all-powerful money
printer that it is these days it's hard
to imagine that not too long ago the
company was in dire straits financially
Marvel were struggling so much that they
had to take a year to try and settle
everything down because the company was
so spread thin leading them to cancel
all of their current animated shows at
about the same time even though they
were still loved by fans and critics so
if you ever wondered why that whole
original run of animes shows all ended
within the same two year span that's why
Marvel saved their asses by selling all
their character rights to various movie
companies leading to the 2000s wave of
films like spider-man x-men blade
daredevil Punisher Hulk Ghost Rider and
the critically acclaimed crowd-pleaser
Alecto after getting things relatively
back on track with that maneuver Fox and
Marvel went back and took a look at that
13 episode outline gave it to two other
people and then they tried to make it as
planned with a few minor tweaks except
all kinds of [ __ ] from real-life kept
bleeding in to make the cartoon suck yes
it sucks I'm sorry
I'm sure someone who enjoyed it at the
time because they were like 5 will tell
me I'm a poser in my opinion is invalid
because I was only one when it was out
and I'm too young I have an opinion on
things blah blah nostalgia goggles blah
blah first thing you'll notice is off is
the team roster
we got Disney Plus nobodies like Hawkeye
vision and Scarlet Witch these days the
MCU has made all of these characters
common knowledge but in the 90s this was
a real huh what set of characters to use
made even more confusing by nobody in
the universe's favorite characters
Wonder Man Tygra and Barragan tygra's
voiced by rogue to cap it off for the
team leader we have ant-man ant-man is
the leader of the Avengers
Jana deserved a better team to be on
than these guys damn it show some
respect to the lady who named the team
and also had sex with magneto once oh
boy that's awkward
ooh stupid sexy Waspinator this lineup
is based on the lesser-known West Coast
Avengers
which seems like an odd choice because
you have all these superstar characters
that people loved and oh wait the rights
issue so remember I said Marvel started
selling character rights to different
companies to make enough money to save
themselves from collapsing that also
affected what characters could appear in
their TV lineups now Spiderman was now
owned by Sony and that's why he didn't
hang out the Avengers until their next
cartoon over a decade later and we can
infer that Captain America Thor Iron Man
and Hulk were now unable to star in
their own shows for quite a while due to
all these complicated contracts about
who owns what thankfully they were able
to have small cameos here and there and
United they stand and I guess stuff like
x-men evolution had that Captain America
episode or that Fantastic Four show that
was full of one-off appearances beyond
that this show was developed after
Batman Beyond was a huge
success and the competition led Marvel
to put more of a futuristic sci-fi spin
on their shows one could assume this is
the reason spider-man unlimited is in a
futuristic city full of flying cars and
robot police United they stand is
supposedly set 25 years in the future
meaning everyone and everything has
shiny chrome plates attached because the
future do you get the future
everything's shining the future original
Avengers lineup are instead like the now
retired first generation of Heroes that
pass the torch to these guys even though
these characters all around the same age
in the show regardless ant-man is
treated like some kind of fusion between
Captain America and Iron Man which is
reflected a lot in his design and
personality it's especially apparent
when he has to briefly interact with
either of those two plus he has the same
voice filter as Tony in that one thing
that was some ride vision I knew I could
have sworn this was the same voice actor
I had to look it up but no Iron Man is
the guy from airplane
god damn Ultron was it necessary to
smash every screen now we're left with a
weird and bland roster of characters a
half-assed future setting with ideas
that they don't quite commit to and a
lot of strange decisions that leave the
show feeling just wrong there were so
many elements that they had to clumsily
include or dance around due to the
real-world corporate politics that the
series arose from and was now likely way
different from that original 13 episode
outline this show is so obsessed with
trying to be like other things that it
has no real identity I feel like the
network and Marvel representatives were
desperate for this to be a success after
the last round of animated shows all
fizzled out but the method they chose to
make it a hit was stealing from
everything that was popular without
understanding why certain elements
worked it's trying to be like Batman
Beyond but not really it's trying to be
like x-men but not really it's trying to
include characters that people wanted to
see but not really
this lack of identity is especially
apparent in the show's characters
before I get too much into the
characters I should throw some quick
context from the plot at use since a
total of 14 people in the world have
seen this show in the future marvel
universe but it's also kind of the
present whatever shut up hank pym leads
a new set of Avengers who are constantly
getting their asses kicked by Ultron
whom Pym created years ago on accident
and then forgot about until he felt the
metal boot connecting with his teeth
Ultron wants to prove his superiority
over the human race by destroying his
creator and then enslaving humanity he
uses his Android minion vision to
mortally wound an Avenger named Wonder
Man then kidnap him a little while later
but the Avengers fill the blank spot in
their roster by just putting parts of
wonder man's mind in division to make
him more human and give him a sense of
morals and then I you've seen age of
Ultron you know all the rest between
battles with Ultron and trying to get
Wonder Man back they usually just fight
whatever threat calls for their
attention be it in space or underwater
or the jungle
wherever simple stuff now on to the
characters having an identity problem
Hawkeye is written and voice acted as if
he was Wolverine when the best there is
so I'm the fall guy right if I'm not
good enough to be seen with the Avengers
maybe I shouldn't be an Avenger Scarlet
Witch has a catchphrase for her powers
now as if she was storm
[Music]
power of web-shooters real Hank Pam is a
Frankenstein's monster of protagonists
and now has no personality he's just a
stand-in for whichever character likely
should have been there at that time
sometimes he's the humble older hero
that everyone looks up to and he's
trying to do his best to match those
expectations in lieu of CAP sometimes
he's the witty charming genius that
always has a crazy scientific plan in
place of Iron Man and gets into
disagreements with the rest of the team
beyond doing those two things we don't
really know or care about him and all
the other characters either admire him
or think he's a blowhard depending on
which mode he's in there's anything I
have to give this show it's that it was
quite progressive to have such Ted
sexual undertones between Hawkeye and
Wonder Man leading to one of the best
written subplots I've seen in an
animated superhero TV show see there's
quite an interesting love triangle
between Clint and Scarlet Witch where
they both vie for wonder man's
affections which subsequently is placed
on vision after they learn that he has
shreds of wonder man's mind after he
goes missing for the majority of the
series it's as if they both miss him so
much that they put the burden of
resolving their unattended romantic
needs on vision suddenly lavishing him
with attention and flirtatiousness but
vision is a newly sentient Android and
isn't emotionally or mentally equipped
for such a complex relationship with
either what I mean Hawkeye isn't gay
that's just me reading too far into it
and the show not knowing how to write a
believable friendship between two males
but like look at him nice move
you should know you taught it to me oh
yeah if I wanted to hit you Birdman
you'd already be roasting on a spit
you're on man I wish Simon was here
that's a rather strange behavior from
your vision
that's okay Wanda it's just wander man
nailing me from in there I owe him one
whatever my idea was more interesting
anyway it's weird seeing this character
before he was ruined with Oh with small
be entire dad energy drinks coffee and
has bandages Hawkeye have fun with that
Jeremy and what is there to say about
Tygra and Wonder Man or Phalke [ __ ] I
forgot he was in this show until I just
now wrote this sentence in the script
that's why I didn't mention him earlier
he's like a street-level hero and he
just kind of shows up one day and then
they accept him into the team like five
minutes later because an angry guy in a
suit told them to [ __ ] these scenes are
a great metaphor for the production on
this show
The Avengers sitting around at a table
trying to do their thing then some
loudmouth with a tie comes in shouting
about all these things they have to do
to improve their public image after the
last generation of heroes dipped add
this add that include this idea you
better make sure this happens and then
of course the whole thing ends up just
being a big toy commercial it's not like
this is a big surprise a lot of
boneheaded decisions were made for
cartoons so they could push more toys
like the 90s spider-man show introducing
Hobgoblin before Green Goblin because
the action figure line had him even when
the writers of the show said they didn't
want to producer Avi rad insisted we all
know how bad his meddling would end up
this entire show feels like that
hobgoblins scenario is happening every
couple of seconds the team are all
wearing complicated suits of colorful
armor with a billion pieces and
accessories elaborate magical girls
style suit up sequences from their
casual costumes to their battle mode
[Music]
Hawkeye's bow apparently snaps in half
and clicks into his backpack even sounds
like an action figure
[Music]
not to mention every member of the team
having different custom costumes
depending on their different
environments like the spacesuits the
jungle safari suits the deep-sea dive
costumes Arctic storm armor looking
Falcons scuba suit has a big bird helmet
oh yes the target exclusive thank you
computer
Ultron is just a head that snaps into
the neck on like three or four different
bodies no looking back now it's clear
that a lot of our childhood was just a
big toy commercial but at least
sometimes it was creative every lazy
repaint of a transformer would be a new
character that had their own distinct
personality and backstory and hell I bet
people would find that show just as cool
if the toys weren't a thing every he-man
character had a really unique design and
gimmick that made their corresponding
toys special but not this United they
stand as full of contrived or completely
unexplained reasons to keep introducing
stupid looking vehicles or dumb
environment based variant costumes so we
can see even more of Hawkeye's midriff
he has a whole suit of armor to wear
when he goes to Alaska just put on a
heavy jacket you [ __ ] and what's with
the stupid letter a badge on the suits
it just conflicts with the costumes
because a lot of these guys already have
an initial on their costume why is puck
eyes hairline so low
or should I say
[Music]
or should I say mind control here father
it's all so cynical and depressing like
this has none of the heart and charm of
those other animated shows which
admittedly had their faults but they
were still really well-crafted
x-men and spider-man were both fantastic
shows that focused so much on character
building and fleshing out their human
subplots between the mindless flashy
action sequences Avengers untitled they
plan has the absolute bare minimum of
character and world building everyone
seems to know who everyone else is
already so characters like Namor or the
Masters of evil are just oh those guys -
the heroes the team themselves all have
one personality trait each that informs
their every decision and the only one I
can remember anything about is Tygra she
has a crippling fear of water because
she's a cat perhaps the most baffling
thing of all as the look of this show
it's hideous in a very unique and
special way let me explain think of a
show like The Simpsons every character
is colored with one flat color and they
don't really have any shading unless
there's a scene with more dramatic
lighting or you know the movie has more
budget then you have a show like Spider
Man the animated series where the
shading is relatively simple
you got your base color and you got your
shadow color this is called cel shading
specifically two tones cel shading a
slightly higher budgeted show like x-men
could do more complicated shading with a
base color a shadow in a light tone to
further imply the light source and even
some heavily black areas that look like
the inking of a comic book
we can call this one the three tone
shading I suppose then you have a show
like United they stand which is the only
show I've ever seen to have a base color
light tone shadow an even brighter light
tone so I guess it's like four tone
shading it makes every character look
like an ugly reflective monstrosity it's
too many conflicting colors and now you
have this giant gradient across
someone's costume from the light source
that just clutters up the already busy
character designs that couldn't have
been cheap or easy to animate and it's
such a bad idea that it makes the show
hurt to look at for long periods of time
my leg fell asleep it hurts so bad the
visual style is like watching a bunch of
Hawaiian shirts tumbling around in a
laundromat dryer with some tie-dye and a
big orange and brown blanket for the
backgrounds which is really unfortunate
considering how detailed these painted
backgrounds are it's just overshadowed
by the gross looking character standing
in front of them in the lack of unique
color palette this visual style is also
not help but the nearly constant
animation errors wise choice we made
when we named you leader of the Avengers
better go after swordsman oh yeah if I
wanted to hit you Birdman it's not a
show I necessarily hate despite how much
I ripped on it but it's frustrating that
turned out how it did considering the
streak of grey shows it broke by being
the way it is it's a series that feels
built by committee for maximum profit
coming off like a highlight reel of
everything wrong with 90s superhero
cartoons without any of their positive
traits people like to pick apart the MCU
for being formulaic and just plugging in
aspects that have been focused test
approved to make money but those films
use those traits because they work and
as much as we [ __ ] we still watch all
of them this is a formula of completely
conflicting and random traits from far
more beloved properties plugged into a
bloated monster that now isn't sure what
it wants to be cut I'm trying so hard
not to compare it to Justice League
because I don't want the comments
section to become a war zone but yeah
well I don't know maybe they'll fix that
next year anyway if you have that much
free time to kill you should check it
out since it's now streaming on Disney
Plus alongside other hit shows like
Super Hero Squad The Mighty Ducks and
Lego Star Wars the free maker adventures
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]